For quite a long time,
the sort of adopted agreed definition for the edge of space has been something
called the Karman line,
which is located at a hundred kilometers above the earth surface.
It was not a legal definition, but it's a definition.
And that's been adopted by the federal seal. Internet's now Aaron Nautique,
which is the world air sports Federation, but it's,
it's a largely unsatisfying definition. Um,
because of course the atmosphere doesn't have an edge. It's a continuous,
um, fluid body.
It has lots of different properties and lots of different regions,
but none of them have rigidly defined edges. And in fact,
the properties change the function of time and solar activity and lots of other
things, a hundred seems almost too perfect, doesn't it? It does.
So recently a paper has been published called the edge of space
revisiting the Karman line.
And this was work done by an astrophysicist named Jonathan McDowell at the
Harvard Smithsonian center for astrophysics.
And he takes a closer look into whether there is a real scientific
definition for the Karman line.
The original Carmen line definition was roughly associated with
the idea that there's a boundary between where aeronautical forces stop
and you no longer get lift from the atmosphere.
Aeronautical lift is a mechanical force.
It's generated by contact with the fluid, the fluid,
obviously being the atmosphere. And if you run out of fluid,
you run out of force. And so the Karman line is you're,
you're sort of wearing our aircraft would have to travel at a speed that's
greater than the orbital velocity in order to get enough lift from wings to stay
in the air. So in this paper,
we looked at the orbits of 43,000 satellites have been tracked over the years.
Yeah. And of course, most of them are way above the Karman line,
but the word substantial numbers that throughout their orbits would pass below
the hundred kilometer line,
getting even closer to 80 kilometers and not just on their last orbit before
they disintegrated, but they have multiple passages this low.
And so right away you can say, okay,
well the a hundred kilometer line doesn't make a lot of sense.
You can't have a satellite in orbit.
And then it comes in and out for a little bit. It's not in space and now,
and then it goes back in space and on and on and on. And so right,
there is some evidence to at least support the idea of revisiting this
definition.
So the second thing he did was actually use an atmospheric model and actually
make the calculations of, for a typical satellite,
where would the drag forces, um,
be enough to sort of cause it to fall back turf?
So like the death zone for settling the deaths, that's exactly it.
So the conclusion he makes is that for a typical kind of space
vehicle,
the gravity will exceed the aerodynamic forces for any object in steady flight
to the altitude.
The altitude lies in about the 70 to 90 kilometer range.
So we factors in the time variation and all of this stuff and,
and finds a range for this limit,
but notes that it's always well below that a hundred kilometer line.
This is just one argument.
Other arguments would look at the structure of the atmosphere,
which is quite complicated, but again, it's divided into specific layers.
Um, mostly based on where the gradient in temperature changes,
these are called pauses. And so at about 85 kilometers,
we've got the Misa pause,
which is the boundary between the Mesosphere and the thermosphere.
And that marks the point,
which is the coldest point in the atmosphere below that point.
The chemical pump position of the atmosphere is mostly steady and above that
you've got different molecules moving in different ways.
And so from atmospheric physics,
there's also a boundary more towards the 80 kilometer line.
So what's really interesting about this argument is to actually appreciate
how close space is because the kilometers a hundred kilometers.
That's not that far away, you can easily drive that in an hour. Um,
so I thought it might be fun to look on a map and actually appreciate, um,
to scale how, how, how far away spaces.
Of course our map is centered on the center of the universe,
which is here in Nottingham.
And the unit that we're going to use to Mark scale on this map
is the humble Lego block.
The height of this brick is 3.2 millimeters. And so I've printed this map,
so that five of these Lego bricks represent a hundred kilometers on
this map to put some things into scale. First, let's talk about airline.
So when we're on a commercial airliner,
we're traveling at about an altitude of 10 to 12 kilometers.
So when we're traveling on a commercial airline,
we're not even traveling at the height of this brick above this map.
So the next scale I'm going to show you is the world record for how high a human
being has jumped out of a balloon to skydive down to earth.
So this record was broken recently by Alan Eustace and he
jumped from a height of 41 kilometers.
So that would wreck represent two bricks on this map.
And so now we want to go up to the Karman line.
And so the debate we're discussing today is whether we define the edge of
space at 80 kilometers,
which is here or a hundred kilometers, which is here,
doesn't seem that high anyway does it.
So I think that's the amazing thing to appreciate.
So this height is a hundred kilometers.
What's really amazing is how small this number actually is,
how close we are to space. So I tip this on this, the edge,
and I've got a hundred kilometer marker here.
You can see that Nottingham is closer to space than it is to London.
And I can get to London in an hour and a half on the train. All right.
So maybe nodding to London doesn't mean very much to you,
but if you're in New York, you're closer to space than you are to Philadelphia.
If you're in Los Angeles, you're closer to space than you are to San Diego. Oh,
let.
Me do a Canadian one.
If you're in Montreal, you're closer to space than you are to Ottawa.
I've got no idea where those places are. All right, cool.
Adelaide for you, but nothing's in your house. So.
Didn't work. When do you become an astronaut?
NASA gives its astronaut wings to anyone who's
trained and flown a successful mission that reaches above 50
miles, which is 80 kilometers. So that's actually the lower limit.
And there's a similar acknowledgement from the U S FAA for civilians
who have piloted a successful flight. Okay.
Is this important? Like,
is this just a bunch of people writing papers or does it matter where space
starts and finishes?
So it, it,
it matters from a scientific perspective because scientists like to study these
sorts of things.
So it's perfectly understandable that people who are interested in atmospheric
physics and the orbits of satellites would care, but it,
it actually does have some wider issues that now touch on issues
of economics and politics and defense and things like that.
So I mentioned there is no international agreed legal definition of
space. There have been for some time moves to make a legal definition,
but that's always been opposed by the U S and you can understand why,
because from a military point of view,
a government wouldn't want to be restricted by international space treaties.
When it's trying to launch child's tude, ballistic missiles,
something like that.
And what about space tourism?
I guess they want it to be as low as possible so they can sell their space
flights.
The other issue. So commercial space tourism is becoming a thing. Now,
as we film this Virgin galactic has just managed to this highlight a vehicle to
82 kilometers by the NASA definition that counts as entering space
by the FAI definition. It doesn't cause they haven't reached the Karman line,
but it would matter very,
very much to a commercial enterprise to be able to say that they can
take people into space. Now, practically speaking, you know,
I think what you would want from a space mission is the experience of
weightlessness and the experience of looking out the window and seeing the earth
as a, as a ball,
you would get that from 80 kilometers as well as you would from a hundred
kilometers.
But like, I look at that and I look at how low that is and I imagined God,
how come you can see the curvature of the earth from such a,
that doesn't seem that high.
I think partly that's because I've printed a map out on a flat piece of paper.
So in reality, this is a curved surface that I'm showing you here.
You might not see it as a complete bowl,
but you would definitely see the curvature of the earth.
You would experience the earth as a sphere.
It becomes quite clear that for commercial enterprise,
you're not going to want to waste money and fuel and an increased risk by taking
people up to a hundred kilometers,
if they can get the same experience going to 80 kilometers. Um,
but part of that experience for people we'll be able,
we'll be being able to say, I have officially been to space.
Where would you be drawing the line? Well, I'm pretty convinced by this paper.
I mean,
it has some pretty sound arguments from a number of different directions.
So I think if there was a move to redefine the 80 kilometer line as the
McDowell line, I think that should go down very well.
But the McDowell says 70 to 90. That's like super vague. Wow.
That's just because scientists, you know,
scientists you've talked to enough of us over the years and we like our aerobars
and we like our confidence intervals.
But if you want to define a line,
you might as well put it in the middle of a region that is well bounded.
This paper has revisited the numbers and the back of the envelope calculations
that gave a hundred, um, are now refined.
And they might not give a more precise number,
but they at least show us that it's not a hundred.
And so it's very unsatisfying to keep it at that level.
I thought it would be fun to actually build up a perspective on the outs to the
other objects in space gets part of this was motivated by the fact that just
last week I went outside, I suppose,
coming home from work and happened to see the international space station go
overhead. It was really bright. It was a beautiful passage. And as always,
I'm struck by looking up and thinking, Oh my God,
there's human beings flying above my head in orbit around the earth.
That's pretty amazing. How far away are they actually up there?
The space shuttle now no longer in existence,
but I couldn't resist getting my Lego out, uh,
used to take astronauts up to the international space station like may Jamison
and that's at 400 kilometers above the surface of the earth.
So in our Lego bricks, if this is a hundred,
we'd need four times that amount. So, uh,
let's do this 13, 14,
16. I feel like I'm on Lego masters 20. Excellent.
All right. So this is the orbit at which human beings continuously
inhabit a space station, orbiting the earth.
And even that is not that high.
I'm slightly less impressed that wasn't your goal.
I think one of the values of human space flight,
one of the real values is cultural, not scientific,
and it's putting human beings high enough to give them that perspective on
space. And if they only have to go that high,
to be able to look out in one direction and see nothing but the infinity of
space and then turn around and look down and see the earth
in enough scope to see not borders and not
resources to be exploited,
but to appreciate that this is the one and only place where life in the universe
exists and to look out to the horizon and appreciate how
razor thin that atmosphere that keeps us safe is
then I think,
I think it's quite amazing that you don't have to get that high up to find a
perspective where you realize just how carious and how
delicate the ecosystem and the geo system on earth is
what else you want to show you? You got humble there. Okay.
So I've got a Nancy Roman and the Hubble space telescope.
One of my favorites and this orbits at an altitude of
540 kilometers, it used to be higher, but it's slowly, even at the altitude,
it suffers from cumulative atmospheric drag over time.
So it's going lower and lower.
And that represents pretty much the highest altitude that the space shuttle
could reach because it was Hubble was designed to be put into earth orbit
at an altitude where the space shuttle could repeatedly go and service it.
And it's a good thing. It did, uh,
because we benefited from those services emissions quite a lot.
And so I've got 20 bricks now and I need to put eight more to get up
to the height of the Hubble space telescope. So one,
two, three, five.
Now we run out of thin bricks.
So we're going to put three more on top. And so that's how,
how high the Hubble space telescope is. All right.
So there's the Hubble space telescope. Yeah, there you go. Success.
Not to scale, of course, the whole space telescope is about the size of the bus,
not about the width of the United Kingdom. Well,
there's lots of satellites up there in orbits GPS,
global positioning satellites orbit at an altitude of 20,000
kilometers above the surface of the earth that would require a thousand Lego
bricks. And I'm not going to build that today. Um,
but I would just note that that would take us 3.2 meters above this
map. Okay. So right through the ceiling. Okay.
And these are satellites they're in geosynchronous orbit.
So they orbit the earth twice a day,
but there are satellites that are even further up.
They're called geostationary orbit.
Their orbital period is matched with the rotation of the earth.
So they orbit once a day,
which means that they are effectively always above the same location,
um, above the equator.
And these are the satellites that give us our weather readings and our
active, our communications relies on this scale. You need 1,789 bricks,
which would take you 5.7 meters above the table.
Oh, that's way up, way up. We're looking here down at the UK and Europe,
how many bricks down is the other side of the earth?
So I said that the GPS satellites are at a thousand bricks above the earth.
Um, but the other side of the earth would only be 640 bricks.
So that's less than the height of the GPS satellites.
If I want it to go to the moon, of course you want to go to the moon? Well,
you would need to travel 19,220 Lego bricks
away, which on the scale would be 60 meters.
So there's been enough recent attention to this idea that the Karman line needs
to be redefined.
That the organizations that deal with aeronautical things and the organization
that deals with astronautical things are proposing to get together in the coming
year to have a symposium,
to look at the scientific and the political and whatever other arguments
go into this to see if we need to actually have a definition of where is space
and what that might be.
We made a video a couple of years ago saying Voyager's left the solar system and
just left the solar system again.
So most things in space don't have a hard edge.
And that means that different definitions can apply. Uh, and you can argue to,
till the cows come home about whether Pluto is a planet or where the solar
system ends or how big is the Milky way.
And to some extent you will never get a satisfying answer because science
often comes with caveats that say, it depends what you mean.
I can tilt it,
but you'll notice that the access of the spin keeps pointing the same direction.
Things. But the main thing it does is creates a huge problem,
because if you're a theoretical physicist, you can do a calculation that says,
okay, so I'm creating all these virtual particles.